we also have to understand our our
public opinion matters on this what we
say what we think how we respond to this
story how we share this story absolutely
matters and I say that specifically
because if you remember not so long ago
uh the the Federal Government tried to
pass the disinformation government board
and they had a disinformation czar that
they were putting forward essentially
what they were trying to do is codify
what they were doing in secret and then
the wide response to that was hell no
are you crazy you want to control speech
in this country you're insane but now
we're finding out oh yeah they were just
doing it the whole time but under a
sub-organization of the DHS under cisa
that's the organization that was doing
this that's the organization doing this
now so so we have to understand they're
only doing this in secret because that's
the only way that they could get away
with this right now we need more of a
bigger pushback and again left right I I
think we shouldn't be consumed with
parties we shouldn't be consumed by
making Mass generalizations about
individuals based on their gang and
their affiliation we should focus on the
individual